right welcome back
everyone and for the second session of
the morning we're going to hear from our
industry Partners who support uh helps
to fund our workshops uh fellow uh
stiens as well as many other aspects of
our programming here at the Institute
and I'm pleased that we have a
representative from each of our five
industry Partners um we've asked
allocated up to 15 minutes for each talk
including questions um so our first
speaker is takamitsu Tanaka from Rock
360 will be joining us via zoom and the
title of his talk is unique challenges
and opportunities in working with
residential real estate data
so Tanaka will appear magically on the
screen good
morning can everyone hear me
okay okay great um so that title that
was just just introduces actually my
talk from last year but it's actually a
great segue I think um so today I'm
going to be talking about llm
applications in real estate uh so my
name is taka I'm the managing director
and head of data and AI at rock rock
360 um let me see all right um so we're
a financial firm and we specialize in
residential real estate Investments and
last year I spoke about the challenges
of doing data science in an industry
where most of the primary sources of
data are unstructured there might be
images they might be PDF documents that
might come in hundreds of different
formats um and then today I'm going to
speak about how the proliferations of
large language models is changing our
approach to these unique challenges um
so this will be a talk on AI and ml
application and not computational Theory
uh you you can consider it an example of
how a medium-sized business is finding
value in AI so we company of about 300
people to 400 people um I think you know
when you read any popular article on
Tech or even business you know there's a
lot of quote hype around Ai and I think
there's you know this you know
multi-billion dollar if not
multi-trillion Dollar Question of like
okay AI is quote here how are business
is going to generate value out of this
and so you can consider this how we a
small company mediumsized company has
started to approach this
question um so one slide on business
context uh we're a financial institution
and we specialize in residential real
estate Investments uh primarily we fund
business loans uh we fund business loans
for investors so these can be so-called
uh Fix and Flip investors who purchase
properties as an opportunity then
renovate them and try to sell them at a
profit and we also have uh customers who
want loans for rental Investments so
maybe they they've identified a property
that they think they can rent out and
then they'll uh get a mortgage through
us and our customers are almost always
mom and pop we don't deal with
institutional Financial entities uh we
Source these properties as well as leads
for our investors and we provide title
and property insurance and other um
additional uh benefits to our customers
but the primary business is around doing
these
loans
and as I referred to earlier a
significant portion of real estate data
is is buried in documents every real
estate loan that weake involves hundreds
of pages of documents if not thousands
uh if there's people in the room who
have had either the fortune or
Misfortune of buying property for
themselves you probably remember if you
haven't um Force erased it from your
memory sitting in an office with a bunch
of lawyers and basically initialing
literally hundreds of pages of documents
for your mortgage so imagine that except
we're business that does that so we have
to do hundreds of those a day uh so the
primary documents can be loan documents
appraisal documents insurance policies
background checks credit reports and
I'll provide examples of most of these
in the coming slides and then for
secondary documents you might want to
dig up uh these same documents for
prospective borrowers past investment
projects you might want to look up
articles incorporations for llc's that
they've set up to be a be a business
person uh you might look up property
descriptions of the properties that
they're trying to
Source um so diving right into examples
uh a really important document for us is
a mortgage uh every residential real
estate uh transaction that's a missing
word I apologize in the United States is
a matter of public record but it's a
public record that is very willfully
obsc so folks that uh do real estate
transactions often set up llc's to kind
of mask the fact that there's a human
behind the deal a really recent and
really public example is uh Supreme
Court Justice Clarence Thomas right it
came to light that uh he like
corporations owned by a billionaire
friend of his had bought a family
member's home right that's a that
document is public record but it
actually took investigative journalism
to figure out what was going on there
and it's very common for our customers
to set up even single use llc's for for
every project so if they've done say 20
Fix and Flip prop uh projects over the
last 10 years they might have set up 20
separate llc's and that makes it really
hard to identify the people who are
doing these transactions and and these
people are customers potential customers
so we have an an interested in
understanding the ecosystem
so this is a typical uh mortgage
document of out of the first page as
well as page 26 so it actually takes
some effort to figure out who's doing
the lending who's doing the borrowing if
there if the borrower is an is a
corporate entity in this case a company
called lisar Holdings LLC then it
actually takes some parsing to figure
out who actually signed which humans
were actually representing this company
and so you have to go through you know
in this case 26 pages to figure out what
was going
on uh when I gave a talk last year I
described our kind of custom algorithmic
approach to to solving this problem
which was a combination of object
detection and custom ner models so we
would do uh object detection on the
document to identify areas like um
notary stamps or signature boxes or
mixed Fields where there was text
written in anything that we thought we
could easily identify using object
detection and then we we uh parsed in
the text through OCR and then we
performed named entity recognition um uh
analyses to figure out okay where's is
their person's name where's their date
where is their corporate entity name and
so on and this is um really difficult to
do as scale I mean you can do it for
most Mor documents and solve a lot of
problems that way but given that there's
infinite variation in how these
documents can be constructed how nuanced
people's names and LLC names can be that
there can be multiple people's names in
a doc in such a document including not
just the borrowers lenders and sellers
and buyers but also agents lawyers
offices things like that um so you know
with GPT and llms our approaches change
significantly uh we perform OCR
extraction on the documents we do really
simple tfidf and regression modeling to
figure out where the relevant portions
of the text are and then we do named
entity recognition through gbt and we do
a lot of prompt engineering to to make
sure that we're getting regularized
outputs and then we can then enter this
information into tabular
form uh another example of what a
document we have to deal with is credit
reports now you might think naively as I
did that hey how hard can it be to get
three simple three digit numbers from
the front page of a report if you look
at this front page of a fairly random uh
credit report uh you if you're like me I
I thought this this page was a nightmare
there's
it's awfully formatted it's very hard to
tell which numbers eax which numbers the
actual report in which numbers the prote
the projection there's random numbers in
there there's random words in there this
is an awfully formatted PDF and it takes
you know
to create a custom Vision model to parse
this is is actually fairly cumbersome um
but gener have ai uh there's a lot of
out of thee boox solutions that can do
this fairly well enough uh another
example of a of of of something that we
have to deal with all the time but this
is a nasty document this is a table of
appraisals um so you off on the left you
have this the subject property that
you're trying to appraise and then an
appraiser will come up with typically
three or more comparable sales that they
say okay this this is a a property that
can be comparable to the subject
property and then you see this really um
nested table full of pretty
idiosyncratic information um people can
fill this uh format in different ways so
there's a lot of
idiosyncrasy um no to appraisers use the
same format so you know if you get say
50 of these documents there could be 20
different formats so this is another
example of something that's fairly nasty
to do if you want to train if you want
to build a custom customized approach
but that llms that we found can can
tackle this fairly well at scale uh
here's another one insurance policies
again lots of text in random places no
standardized format uh lots of weird
things lots of weird check marks dates
things like that again really difficult
to do a computer vision model for
this um and since I only have 15 minutes
let me just go through and another
example of an llm application that we
found is in normalizing the
FR there really you know there's a lot
of variance in terms of style in terms
of local specific jargon uh nomenclature
there can be typos so it's again very
challenging to build custom approaches
to extract information or classify the
text right for for example if you wanted
to classify something that's a
renovation opportunity the text can be
written in a ton of different tones so
it's it can be hard to figure out if
it's a renovation opportunity or a
recently renovated property for instance
um extraction of specific features like
close to public transit or fixer upper
again you can use you know things like
keyword extraction and keyword
identification but it becomes really
hard when some of the keywords are
really local specific right public
transit has very different proper nouns
associated with it in San Francisco
supposed to New York for
example um so you can do something
really naive like ask an llm to generate
a list of keywords uh for specific um
for specifically use cases so here we're
asking
to find comparable properties and then
also uh or find keywords that might be
useful for finding other properties like
this
one and also finding keywords that that
describe a potential for
renovation and LM LM can do this of
course um but what we really want to do
isn't extracting keywords but rather
extracting features right we want some
standardized set of features is like hey
is there a kitchen island are there
amenities like balconies or patios is it
close to public transit is it near water
is it near nature is it convenient is it
near good schools things like that um so
coming up with a rather rigid data
schema and then asking an llm to parse
the description and populate this schema
is something that we found a lot of
success in early days still but a lot of
success so what you can do is you can
take these really regular property
descriptions and then have a regularized
data schema that then you can use to do
things like find outliers in or unique
properties uh with uh uh sorry that are
relative to its prop uh its neighbors uh
you can do clustering and segmentation
you can use these features for valuation
models or identify uh properties that
might be good opportunities for flips
and then in the research phase uh we're
also doing property image analysis
images are key data resource especially
if you're trying to find distressed
Properties or if you're trying to
evaluate uh borrower projects that are
in progress so we're experimenting with
Custom Image models uh including those
that use uh that are kind of llm add-ons
uh to gauge things like overall
condition of the home to uh look for
signs of damage to look for signs that
there's unfinished or ongoing
construction
work and just to wrap up so the overall
impact so far uh using llms to extract
information from documents uh is saving
tens if not hundreds of person hours per
loan application and for a business that
involves so many manual PDF or manual uh
inspection of PDFs this is a huge uh
process change uh it enables and
accelerates data schematization and
normalization it increases the volume
and quality of the data that that we
have in relational T table form uh that
then expands the data that we can use in
algorithms of course um and then this
approach allows for at scale mapping of
investors their corporate entities and
their transaction history whereas you
know going through these tens of
thousand documents per month that are
relative that mortgage documents per
month that are relevant to our industry
space and doing that on a manual basis
is just not
tractable um so just to wrap up uh so
the way we're finding value in AI in the
in its early days while being cautious
of its risks is um we focus on
extraction and parsing and not creative
tasks uh we make llms provide responses
into a rigid framework
so
for any task that we look into
automating through AI uh we Benchmark
its accuracy against either previous
custom ml approaches or manual
approaches um right now we're having
every outp output be reviewed by human
uh you know we we're in the business of
doing loans these are legal legally
binding documents so uh every person had
or every every deal has a person that's
accountable for it uh one challenge that
we see going forward is the lack of
generalizability for prompts that are
engineered right so if you give say chat
gp4 a specific prompt that you found it
to work for specific use case what
happens when a new version of GPT comes
out or when they silently change the
model or how do you then try to switch
models or use something else uh we see
that as a significant challenge um going
forward um and I think this will be a
kind of an industrywide problem or you
know a a global problem that people will
have with these kinds of prompt prompted
uh
AIS um so that's it uh thank you I think
my time is up um yeah I'm happy to take
any
questions all right we could do a quick
question I think you can hear from the
room try that oh okay
just the question uh so so I see you're
using gp4 and then you're doing the ocrs
now with gp4 vision do you still need to
do the OCR the other steps yeah that's a
good question I think so we need to
explore there are two thoughts off the
top of my head here one is pricing so if
there's a cloud platform such as like
Google Vision offering OCR for a certain
price I doubt that piece of the OCR is
going adding OCR to open AI is or GPT is
going to be cheaper I think there's some
something about competitive pricing
there another concern I have is how much
visibility we have into what the AI is
parsing we don't want to get into a
place where we feed any platform a PDF
and then we we're not sure what text
that it used uh with by one advantage of
having a separate OCR layer is that we
know exactly what text we fed it and we
can also control what to feed the
algorithm instead of feeding it the
entire text because we know a lot of the
text is not going to be
relevant thank
you